Justin Timberlake under investigation  for posting this selfie of himself  during early voting on Monday yeah it's  crazy  unofficial from the District Attorney's  Office in Shelby County Tennessee it  confirms the news to et the 35 year old  is holding up his voter access card  inside the polling booth and wrote in  part quote I just flew from LA to  Memphis to Rock the Vote no excuses make  good people there could be early voting  in your town too  yeah only problem snapping pics so we're  taking video from inside the voting  booth is illegal in Tennessee the DA's  office can't comment on whether they've  spoken to Justin but if JT's found  guilty of the misdemeanor  it could mean 30 days in jail and a  potential $50 fine et has reached out to  Justin's rep for comment  you